hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now in
this episode I plan to do something very
very stupid because I'm about to take
this Cyclops into the territory of where
the seal of Ivan's are and if you know
what that means it means I'm probably
going to die a horrible death and I'm
going to lose my Cyclops and everything
I know and love is going to explode and
die but before we do that I've actually
made some changes I'm back now to the
release version of the game and I've
tweaked the same file so that all of the
things that I've opened before are now
no longer open so if I go over to life
bot that may sound complicated it's not
cheating I didn't actually give myself
anything all I did was delete some
savegame files that made it so that this
was no longer opened and here it is it
actually worked I can't believe it so if
I open this I mean the retail version of
it now this should give me the creature
decoy so I have back now I have that now
it works and I'll take this first-aid
kit because why not and I got the life
pod for crew log so the unfortunate
thing is that pretty much everything
I've ever picked up is no longer or is
there to be picked up again but the
benefit is I think I still have
everything that I picked up thus far so
I didn't lose anything and I've only
gained that which is new that I haven't
already gotten like these creature
decoys so if I go back into my Cyclops
right now
welcome when I go up here although it's
good to be welcome aboard
alright but let me get back here and
actually talk to my people about this
thing thanks buddy
and AH but I thought it was here the
Cyclops upgrades fabricator or maybe the
decoy hasn't made their maybe the decoy
is made somewhere else like in the
actual fabricator because that's what
that would be yes hey there it is
there oh I pissed myself in such joy
over that fact I've got that and I can
make that no problem titanium copper
wire in the battery I've got bonus
batteries sitting back in my old base
I've got a ton of them so if I'm going
to reclaim those because that's actually
good because it doesn't matter if those
batteries are full or empty no matter
what they are you can still use them and
if I'm going to go against the sea
dragon Leviathan or not the sea dragon
leviathans it's alive and the Reaper
leviathans that I'm going to need me
some gosh darn gosh darn decoys but
after that you may be wondering am I
just charging into these license
Oh willy-nilly just to get my kicks and
giggles doesn't know I save you Oh
intrepid viewer of vine no I'm going in
there because there is still the shield
module and the sonar fragment and I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to get
both in this one episode but I'm gonna
try my damnedest to do that and I'm not
gonna beach my goddamn Cyclops here I'm
gonna go in there I'm gonna get the
batteries and I'ma pop back out and I'm
gonna make myself some goddamn decoys
but in the mountain area and in the
Koosh zone I've been told there are
wrecks which contains that which I need
and what I need in fact is our quarry
for oh I need to put that back in my
Cyclops because I'm done but what is in
those wrecks is something so incredibly
important that I won't be able to get
back down into the briny depths without
them yes the shield and the other thing
that I mean the sonar the mapping
feature which can help me navigate and
also know
where the heck II I'm going in life so
with those two tools and Geoffrey
Billy's a miser marshals that don't
examine all but with those two tools I
should be able to get back down there
and I should be able to make that which
I need to be able to carry on with my
life now energy pulse origin I already
know about that that was the mountain
area which I'm already headed back
towards now some of you said that the
mountain area or the gun did have a
working portal in it and I think I
frankly remember that I think I actually
remember powering it up and activating
but it may not be activated just yet so
while I go backwards and I go over
towards the Reaper leviathans I'm going
to read these comments here I don't have
time to make lockers just yet but
everybody thank you so much Michael warm
Mel who said I'm not exactly sure but
maybe making the submarine a neon yellow
color is not helping you go unnoticed
mark well I just want to die in a yellow
submarine is that so much for me to ask
so and then Sam Danny said this episode
should have been called Mark's massacre
because of how many fish the fish he
killed out of their homes and the poor
civilian boomerang he murdered
I mean think twice about well here's
something I thought twice about maybe he
deserved it you don't know what that
boomerang did you don't know that that
boomerang was not the conspirator leader
of all the Leviathans in this entire
ocean and unlikely and as crazy as that
may sound it could be true I'm going to
sign up from running because I know for
a fact I might actually be in reaper
leviathan territory
yo yo yo yo oh it's so scary alright so
scary
alright so scary okay then there's Paul
per underscore tf2 the sniper with
skills who said mark don't worry the dev
thankfully made it so if the cyclops
does meet the watery grave the creative
build items can be reclaimed salvaged
from the remains of the cyclops if you
can reach it yeah I know I get a Karen
I'm starving it's real good to know
about also all the titanium for pressure
compensators aren't gone forever so if I
do eventually crash this sumbitch and it
does die to a Reaper Leviathan attack I
vow I will not restart my save I will
take that punishment for what it is and
that is why I'm going to be unbelievably
careful in these briny depths because I
am putting a challenge to myself - not
cheap
and I think resetting my save I only get
a few of those in the entire series that
I got to do so I gotta be very careful
about that also max weights that mark
try to put up your Keep Calm Kitty
poster in the Cyclops now that it's
updated and yes I've been keeping the
keep Conger Kitty poster right here on
me the entire time because it keeps me
happy at night keeps me warm and makes
me feel comfortable in this dark dreary
environment where everything is death I
feel just a little bit of comfort which
is nice I need to get a few more of
these I gotta empty out my inventory
very soon I've got all these batteries
but I'm gonna make a bunch of decoys oh
come on I thought it was 9 early today
bear eye god damn it damn you damn you
to hell
I mean someone with an empty one not you
not you I've got so much titanium cheese
I didn't think I'd have too many
resources here I need some of these
batteries and I need some titanium thank
you for yeah and then what else did I
need I needed the
what did I need copper wire do I have
any copper left man that was the one
thing that I was actually running out of
I don't even know if I have any come I
have copper but only enough to make one
copper wire I want at least two of these
decoys here yes I've got some more okay
so I make the copper wire like that
shovel ski and then I make another one
of those like that shaft balloon ski and
then I'm gonna make myself a god damn
decoy tube which is openly going to be
very very useful and I'm going to use it
in emergencies which is going to happen
literally all the time that I'm in the
ocean
I'm a panic and fired off it I may not
look think twice about it but I'm gonna
do that I'm gonna build a locker right
next to it so I can have all the storage
for that the torpedo is going to make
there but I'm going to load this bad boy
up I'm going to load this bad boy up and
I'm going to eat some of these bad boys
here
they just purged everything so I might
as well get some more in my gullet damn
it freakin inventoriable okay whatever
that's gonna be good enough and I'm
gonna drop off the rest of the [ __ ]
that's in my inventory because I'm just
loaded to the ears with all of this
Garbo all of this Garbo kind of so much
Garbo third avenue boo-boo okay that's
gonna have to do it creature decoy I'm
going to put you away for now because I
don't really need you in the moment I
think the battery's too and then I'm
gonna try I'm trying to put the Keep
Calm Kitty poster but I don't think it's
gonna work is it all right here we go
come on please please
why why why would you deprive me of this
game developers why also I know that the
game developers have apparently made a
markiplier doll somewhere in the game I
don't know how to get to it but I am
aware that that exists so without
further ado let's save anyway just
you know why not like why wouldn't I do
that why wouldn't they say but I'm gonna
save and then I'm diving down hope I'm
facing the wrong direction here but I'm
gonna dive down I'm about to go oh of
course it's gonna be night right now but
we're gonna go down into the briny
depths we're gonna see we're gonna see
exactly what we need to know about down
here oh boy how do boy oh boy howdy aw
boy
Oh God okay so all I need to do is I
need to go down in there into the couch
zone and I need to find myself in the
pitch darkness that it is need to find
wherever the hell the goddamn wreck is
down here and that's not the wreck that
I went to looking for the the plans for
that thing that I can't remember what it
is right now because I my brain is now
working but I'm looking for the other
wreck that is a part of the coos toned
specifically not the deeper areas I'm
looking specifically for the wreck in
the coos zone and given that I can't see
Jack diddly
I am goddamn gonna die I'm not gonna
give up because I'm above the mushroom
area which is far north and I think just
to the west or just to the east of this
I just pissed myself again but I think I
see it in front of me the Koosh zone is
over there I believer is that the aurora
I need to go lower I'm not a harbor
center let me cycle okay so I'm not very
deep well that's probably my problem
right now but I'm pretty sure that
somewhere below me
adjacent to the mushroom forest is the
Koosh zone or nearly this would be fine
ordinarily I'd be totally fine with this
everything would be hunky-dory ah but
death lurks around every corner in the
ocean and I am going to braise it
embrace it I'm going to brace it and
then embrace it then punch it in its
goddamn face I'm gonna die and
everything is gonna be horrible but
until that moment comes I'm gonna go
into the crew zone if I keep shouting my
plans any more reassuring or I might
just make you guys worried out there I
see it okay I spied some Koosh I got
some sweet dank couch over there okay so
I don't I don't have the coordinates
specifically oh hi you guys don't come
near me I'm silent running I'm silent
running you would never bother someone
that's silent running with glasses would
you
okay that was if the sound of those
sharks was that the sound of something
bigger okay somewhere here in the
goddamn cusan hi oh I hate you I hate
you I hate all of you oh I hate you all
so much
okay somewhere down here goddamn coup
zone there is a wreck I don't think I'm
gonna find the wreck by going oh so
tantalizingly slow
what is that what is that down there
that's a life pod I didn't know that
there was a life pod in the couch zone I
thought there was a rack is no this
isn't what I'm looking for when I what I
saw this bill specifically I don't have
the exact coordinates for it but they
were specifically there was specifically
a rack here a giant wreck not just a
life pod but frankly I didn't even know
if there was a life pod here in the
first place I honestly had no idea so I
don't know what this is going to contain
if anything useful it might be something
that I already have the fact that
there's a life up here right but I'm oh
my god okay thank you for that okay
hello I am I must have been something I
already had the plans to okay but I
don't remember ever getting a life pod
down here I don't ever remember that
like pots well that doesn't sound
familiar but I decided been here I'm
going to get back with a don't feel safe
out here on my own especially with the
goddamned lava first okay so we got a
new dataset here Hong Kong and I don't
know if it's going to be something new
for me but I'm going to look at it log
data downloads life pods like pod twelve
this is medical officer Dan be in Life
pod twelve I'm braking atmosphere at
high velocity planet fall in 20 seconds
explosion taking fire going into a spin
attempting
landed in an area of significant alien
activity encountered predators in the
Leviathan class highly aggressive
spectroscope skinner assigned them
Reaper oh so that's how they got their
names I don't remember if I've ever read
that you don't find me on board the ship
resume I miscalculated and save yourself
oh this is new one specimen in tempted
to swallow the lifepod doing extensive
damage in the process only be able
option is to make for the safety of the
Aurora crash site I've retrieved the
data box with the alien creature decoy
blueprint and enough resources to
fabricate a couple decoys the swims
longer than the decoy lifetime but it
should be just enough to keep them busy
if you don't find me on board the ship
presume I miscalculated and save
yourself oh oh I can't even match doing
that swim I can't even imagine doing
that that would be the most horrifying
swim
anyone's ever doesn't it like what is
that hey back off okay you back off oh
mama
okay so what I get to do is I got to
find I got to find I got to find this
big wreck because I know there's a
bigger wreck here and that explains why
that life pod was upside down and in a
bad way whoo wait I think I see
something yeah that's definitely a wreck
okay in that wreck supposedly I say
supposedly with a lot of grain of salt
happening but supposedly in that wreck
is the plans for the either sonar or not
sonar
so either way I need to go in there I
need to go in there and I need to
digging biggest cave down there I'm
gonna go ahead and assume that's not a
cave that I can go into but there are
some low framerates around yeah I need I
need I need I need I need I need ice
like I'm playing on a potato here I'm
gonna go in there anyway cuz I'm brave
or whatever here we go diddly doo I'm
off squadala
I'm off oh my god oh my god this oh
that's janky oh here starvation imminent
you shut up oh man I'm just got so that
was good Ian what did they give me
there's got to be something else in here
then skadoosh skinny husky skidoo
skadoosh skadoosh off skadoosh who's in
here Oh such sweet frames brah oh yes
disinfected water brah
oh I need the laser cutter for this I
need oh oh my god why the framerate so
long here I think this still has the
crap battery in it so eventually I'll
need to upgrade this to the better
battery that definitely is not working
but hopefully I can I have the swim
charge fins so if I swim around enough
while holding this thing and should get
me a double dagger of a little more
power is there anything in here that I
can use just a battery I guess it's
technically useful but not literally
useful I'm about to run out of oxygen
aren't I and I don't see ah haha so
janky okay I'm out of here
mater your baby doesn't seem to be
charging it at all I don't care I gotta
go
alright gotta go alright Oh charged it
one per shaunt okay but it didn't give
me it didn't give me the sonar upgrade
and that's not a factor of the save this
is on the retail version so that should
be there but there also is another
location
for said device so if it's not in
another spot in there somewhere then
that means that it's got to be somewhere
else and that means I got to go to the
mountainous area which by itself is
currently interest why I don't know what
I had but it was something so I think
I'm going in the right direction for the
seems to be a lot of enemies out there I
don't like that very much but there seem
to be a lot of them okay but it's fine
it I think I'm heading towards where the
mountains are I can probably stand to
make a little bit of noise in fact I'll
cut it I'll cut it when I don't need it
I know I'm cavitating but I'll cut it as
soon as I don't need it anymore
okay somewhere here there be love I
advanced and again I'm gonna be real
stupid and I'm gonna see if they bother
me because at some point I'm gonna have
to test this out if I'd rather do it in
a controlled environment than have it
happen to me you know what I mean you
guys know what I'm talking about guys
know what I mean I'd rather see for
myself and then run with a few decoy
then have them just spring upon me this
is weird because I swear I swear they're
supposed to be leviathans around here
okay so far so good
so far so good okay um either I'm
extremely lucky or beige ain't something
because I'm wrong the bone jerk
hey buddy no need to worry about me it's
just us it's a big yellow submarine
friend Oh cover give me a big hog give
me a big ol hug
so either either I'm lucky or they
change something which is concerning to
say the least because it makes me feel
like they just took the Reaper
leviathans and put them all very densely
in one location which I love it I don't
think that's any better than what I had
going on there maybe that's any better
at all but I am in the mountainous area
which means in here somewhere there are
more wrecks and I know there is the one
wreck that's draped across the bodies of
like the underwater islands or the
underwater mountains or whatever you
want to call them and I think that's got
one of the things and then in the
mountainous area themselves as I piss
myself there are more wrecks with more
of these specialized equipment and I'm
guessing it must be some sort of
randomize because that's what it was
before when I was trying to find
everything so with that being said I'm
going to find one more wreck and then
that's going to be the end of this
episode because I want to try to find
something something oh I can't see [ __ ]
oh here we go keep getting closer we're
getting who is that a date abox that
looks like a dative box I don't know if
that's gonna be the data box that I'm
looking for who keeps me silently run
here no no no you didn't see anything I
got to get me some food and then I get
to give me some goddamn repairs because
I'm not doing 100 then okay on this woo
boy
Pirlo frames again hopping out there
whether or not it is a good idea I'm
still gonna do it okay anybody hoppity
hippity hoppity oh-oh I didn't get any
III hey hey hey I didn't get it oh my
god there's a rack here how long was
there reckon you oh you don't I think I
just saw the inside of my soul there for
a second there but I think I'm okay
there are a lot of juice bags here they
want a piece of me but I won't let them
have it
oh that's okay you'll survive big guy
cuz I didn't get anything from there and
I'm pretty sure I'm only not getting
things
ah [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] open this open
this up in this hey don't hit me while
I'm opening something that just be rude
here we go go go go go go all right I
don't think they can follow me in here
so I should be okay looking for some
sort of it I there we go
all right then can we do something good
nah nothing again all right
I'm gonna keep looking around just in
case you never know
come on you come on caught on got it
there we go keep swimming back and forth
is this going to charge you this is
charging it they're doing you they're
doing what you need how does that feel I
feel good feel good feel charged find it
whoa hi I got a dated terminal let's go
there's another one in here
Cyclops fire suppression system does
awesome that sounds awesome
I don't know what that do but that
sounds whoo awesome okay I want to get a
little bit of start oh I can make it out
of there how do you make it out in time
I don't know if I'm gonna have enough
power for this but I'm gonna try to make
it maybe I'll make it I don't know if
I'm gonna make it oh I should probably
go I'm gonna go Oh low framerates can't
see [ __ ] get through the goddamn door
please oh god where do I go I've totally
gone where I'm going oh boy I'm gonna be
doing this in the dark where is my
goddamn boat oh it's over here
oh I'm an idiot yo yo yo yo ed shubbu
ski no okay
well that could have gone better or
could have gone worse so I'd say that
did marginally good for exactly the way
it was so with that being said I'm all
at time for this episode so I am going
to leave it here thankfully I didn't
encounter a Leviathan but that just
means that I'm going to encounter a
Leviathan in the next episode no matter
what I do because I'm going to force
myself to encounter a Leviathan in next
episode so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know how I'm doing
down to comes below I did get the fire
suppression system which means that over
here I hope that means that over here it
should listen to recipe and it's oh my
god when did I get that did I actually
get that well I don't have enough
polyaniline for that oh it's a lot of
[ __ ] and it needs but hey it's pretty
good so I've got those two recipes
apparently now and that means I'll be
able to do more damage with it so thank
you everybody so much for watching it
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]